Miley Cyrus's career has been shockingly
long and super varied we've got all the
backstage footage and behind the scenes
stuff from Hannah Montana all the way to
Black Mirror baby yeah we're going old
school if like the rest of us you can't
stop singing I can buy myself flowers
thanks a lot Tick Tock you're probably
in the know about the relationship that
turned into a viral Trend Miley Cyrus
and Liam Hemsworth met on the set of the
movie adaptation of Nicholas sparks's
the last song way back in 2010 and
seeing how the two of them were when
they first met and started getting to
know each other really puts the whole
relationship situation into perspective
it's kind of cool huh it's incredible
Miley was only 18 years old and Liam was
hardly any older like only a couple of
years they were both still working on
figuring themselves out and to be thrown
into the spotlight the way they were
that's intense for anybody and there's
plenty of behind the scenes photo out
there that shows what it was like for
Miley and Liam when they weren't playing
their characters even the way Miley
talks about him when she was that age
and in that situation it's pretty
telling working with Liam was a lot of
fun because we're a lot alike but we're
also very different she'd talk about
their similarities and differences that
were uncovered as they got to know each
other sounds kind of like a relationship
right well when you're that young it's
kind of tough to know exactly the
difference between romantic
relationships and working relationships
those lines got blurred working so
closely together set the groundwork for
the love that went on for years until it
ended which we know didn't turn out so
well so to anyone who's seen the last
song it's more than obvious their
chemistry was off the charts Liam talked
openly about growing closer with Miley
during filming and it's pretty clear
that the couple to be knew how to have
fun with each other we've had a lot of
fun she's we've come really close
through the shoot and it makes the
scenes a lot easier they were even
poking fun at each other while they had
to interview each other I know he's
really cute and all but he has a picking
his nose problem I'll look over and his
finger will be literally in his brain
and where did all that time go it's kind
of hard to believe that they went from
this to this but a decade sure does
change people she was great at being a
romantic lead but she really could not
be tamed because her role in Black
Mirror that was a whole other Story the
scenes in this which I think are very
unlike anything she's done before
Miley's Black Mirror episode was a very
far cry from the last song and it was
actually a very important moment in her
career seeing her appearance in the
episode was surprising to a lot of
people by that point she was more into
her music anyway but according to writer
and Creator Charlie Brooker casting
Miley was a no-brainer she's been
through a lot of the stuff that happens
in in this story they wanted a real pop
star to fit their pop star character and
duh my Riley's an epic pop star it
bloody helps if you've got someone who
knows what they're doing and the
creators weren't the only one who
thought Ashley oh and Miley C were very
much alike in an interview with variety
Miley literally said the similarities
between her and her character were so
striking it made her laugh out loud oh
like honey I played that role before and
while she may have a lot in common with
the character it was still tough for her
to fully transform into Ashley and did
you know Miley actually kept the wig she
wore I thought you may want to ask
Ashley herself but it wasn't just her
playing a part the part changed a bit so
it was even more perfectly Miley she
actually had a shocking amount of say in
making changes to the script and Ashley
oh kinda changed the star's career she
had a little thoughts on the script and
gave us a lot of insight and
observations that we then reversed into
the script different roles of broader
different fans and how many people do
you know were regular Hannah Montana and
Black Mirror Watchers you do sometimes
lose some of those bands that came with
you from the beginning so another role
that got her a whole lot of new fans the
2015 movie The Night Before how many
stars can you pack into a movie well as
many as you want if you consider the
fact that the cast for the night before
was stacked and we're talking Seth Rogen
Joseph Gordon-Levitt Anthony Mackey
Lizzie Kaplan James Franco Nathan
Fielder Mindy Kaling what's funny though
is there wasn't really a role to be
played Miley was just doing her and it's
clear based on the behind the scenes she
knew how to make the set fun and wasn't
afraid to push boundaries in the role
okay but has she ever been scared of
pushing boundaries we do not expect
anything less Miley's castmates were
clearly impressed by her capabilities
and loved having her on set but like who
wouldn't she ended up being just so cool
and down to earth and and such a pro not
everything Miley did was a total hit
though like So Undercover it was this
comedy that came out back in 2012 there
was no playing herself here she fully
transformed into her character and even
got a taste of the Collegiate life in
sorority boot camp going to sorority
boot camp was probably one of the
weirdest I I felt like Molly for sure
now that sounds Wild and the wild didn't
stop there that year Miley starred as
Lola in an indie film called LOL
according to Miley her co-star is
entirely to thank for getting her cast I
just want to say thank you to me because
she's the main reason I got involved and
yeah we're talking about the Demi Moore
and without her I wouldn't be on the set
without her I wouldn't be who I am
sitting here Miley's a boss at what she
does so she managed to discover how
similar she was to her character
recognizing how they were different just
really delving into every aspect of the
part and I felt exactly what Lola was
going through and plenty of Disney
Channel stars want to distance
themselves from the way the fans who
followed them in their earlier days see
them so getting into adult roles can
kind of be a struggle but Miley honestly
she just nailed it I hope they see uh
all of us in a new light and at the time
Miley thought that doing LOL would show
fans that she'd matured but we can't
ignore how big an icon Hannah Montana
was for the OG fans so we gotta talk
about it well most of us remember Hannah
Montana the series about a girl living a
double life what is actually pretty
special to see is the behind the scenes
according to Backstage footage Miley was
having a total blast on set and it's not
hard to get hit with a major wave of
nostalgia watching the show being made
maybe her new song flowers will get out
of our heads and The Best of Both Worlds
will make a comeback okay but for real
she was pulling like triple Duty acting
and singing on set and of course going
on tour knowing what we know about Miley
it's pretty impossible to imagine her
getting nervous but looking at the old
footage the nerves were definitely there
and we can't blame gamer that's a lot of
pressure backstage I get ready to do my
contacts by actually not thinking about
the concert because otherwise I get very
very nervous and the pressure almost
caused her to break years later Miley
actually confessed that starting to tour
when she was 12 left her with some vocal
cord issue that lasted a really long
time this is from overuse of the vocal
cords but even if things were tough it
did not hold Miley Cyrus back from doing
what she wanted her way and looking at
everything she's done well she's pretty
much done all of it what could possibly
be next a Miley Cyrus talk show perhaps
I haven't really had that in the past 10
years the star has talked about the
potential of a Miley Cyrus talk show in
the future and while nothing's been
totally planned it seems like she'd be
into it and we'd definitely be into it
so what do you think about Miley's
career where do you think she's had it
next let's talk about it in the comments